this week on brian ross investigates
cause of death the forensic pathologist
involved in cases from elvis
to kurt cobain to jonbenet ramsey weighs
in tonight on the george floyd case
well i think it's going to be difficult
to truly get a fair trial
the prosecution says there's no doubt
george floyd died
because of officer derek shoving's knee
restraint technique
seen in the phone video but the official
autopsy
also found that floyd had a heart
condition and a potentially
lethal level of the drug fentanyl in his
system
in another new document baker says that
is a fatal level of fentanyl under
normal circumstances
that's the way the game is played dr
wick are you saying then that the
medical examiner essentially was trying
to cover up
her derek shovin and the minneapolis
police department
plus what's behind the surge in children
and teenagers at the southern border
is the biden administration up to the
challenge
i can say quite clearly don't come we're
in the process of getting set up
please don't come doesn't mean anything
here this decision is weighed heavily
and a wish by the president of the
united states isn't going
to change that and this week's winners
and losers in the media
taking off the gloves on the biden white
house
why were you not prepared for this from
the lawn crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin with cause of death
that will be the central issue in the
trial next week of minneapolis police
officer derek shovin
the official autopsy called the death of
george floyd a homicide
pointing to the knee to neck restraint
technique used by chauvin
but the autopsy also listed possible
heart issues that floyd had
and what the autopsy called a
potentially lethal level of the drug
fentanyl rhonda that's right but george
floyd's family commissioned a private
autopsy done by the renowned pathologist
dr michael baden who presented his very
definitive and different conclusion
at a press conference last year
the autopsy shows
that mr floyd had no underlying
medical problem that caused or
contributed
to his death the
cause of death in my opinion
is asphyxia due to
compression of the neck which
as mr
trump indicated can uh interfere with
blood flow
and oxygen going to the brain and
compression
of the back which interferes with
breathing
and we're joined now by forensic
pathologist dr sarah weck dr weck
thank you for being here this evening as
you know this case could well come down
to
the autopsy and the findings is it
possible that he died of something other
than
the knee-to-neck restraint were there
enough drugs in his system that could
have killed him
was the heart condition enough that
could have killed him
thank you for affording me the
opportunity to speak with you about this
fascinating highly important case
um pleasure to chat with you my answer
to your
question succinctly to begin with is no
i do not believe that um mr floyd died
from fentanyl toxicity um or from
hypertensive arterioscratic
cardiovascular disease
or a combination of those two yes it is
true
that the fentanyl level in this case was
high enough
to kill somebody but it is also true
that people with that level
and higher levels do not die i don't
know what his
tolerance level was that may he may have
built up
over the years the point is that when
he was stopped by the cops for that
counterfeit
money order whatever it was and so on he
was
somewhat you could say aggressive
he was resisting arrest you could say
you know those are other things
but that is not the scenario
that one would find of an individual who
is going to succumb
to fentanyl he did not just succumb to
fentanyl
during the course of the struggle where
where just
a moment or so before he stopped
breathing
before he stopped speaking before he
stopped making sounds
before he stopped making any movement
and then all of a sudden
he died that is not the way it would
have happened
in this case and dr as you know the
official
autopsy report does open the door a bit
for the defense to argue in fact
that's what killed him it's not
definitive is it and no
no it's not definitive and you know i
don't want to say anything of an odd
hominem nature
and i don't know the medical examiner
i'm sure he's a competent forensical
dollars and so on
but you know uh for a medical examiner
to kind of smooth over
um a a case
involving a police-related death that is
about
as unexpected and atypical as it would
be
for me to want a drink of water
sometime later this afternoon and that's
surprising
that's the way 80 90 of my colleagues
play the game it's not a massive
malevolent
conspiracy in which they get together
with cops around the country
and decide what they're going to do
that's the way the game is played
well dr wick are you saying then that
the medical examiner essentially was
trying to cover up
for derek shovin and the minneapolis
police department
i would not use the word cover-up um
sounds pretty close i would use the
phraseology
kind of smooth over kind of smooth over
um um that's that's what i would say
um is that an advocation of his duty you
think to be uh forthright
i believe that it is an abdication of
his duties
of medical examiners around the country
who go along
and allow district attorneys alone alone
to determine whether charges will be
filed in police-related deaths they have
nothing to say
they speak forensic scientifically they
have no input
they don't conduct inquests they don't
follow through with public comments and
so on you have all of these
police-related deaths and especially
when um
the african-american population is
involved um
michael brown in ferguson um and
missouri freddie gray in baltimore
sandra bland in texas um eric garner
in new york uh arbury and georgia
tamir rice and cleveland look at those
cases and see
what was done criminally and every one
of the cases which i had referred to
there were settlements civilly a
multi-millions of dollars
and of course 27 million dollars now uh
settlement already in the derek chavin
george
floyd case what does that tell you um
our city councils
and county governments and state
governments rolling over and just
opening up their wallets if they feel
they have a case to defend
then defend it but no they
just don't do anything criminally cops
walk away
but let the families proceed and we the
taxpayers
will pay the money um um with no
knowledge or input on our part
that's what i am saying dr wecht who
served more than two decades as the
coroner and medical examiner
in allegheny county pennsylvania has
been involved or consulted
in some of the most high-profile death
cases in recent memory
including elvis presley kurt cobain john
bernay ramsey
dr how do you think this case of george
floyd compares
and can he get a fair trial can derek
schilvin get a fair trial with all that
publicity
well i think it's going to be difficult
to truly get a fair trial
i find it hard to imagine and what does
the prosecution do and they must know
now the defense for derek shovin
is going to try to build his case around
the presence of the fentanyl
i hope that they will listen to your
program and they will take my suggestion
of going back and getting every fentanyl
drug toxicity death
signed out by the hennepin county
medical examiner's office you don't have
to go
any further it's a big size jurisdiction
go back for a year or more
get every fentanyl case look through the
police investigative reports
comments from families and friends about
the circumstances the scenario uh that
existed when that individual died and
there is
your answer there's your rebuttal to the
defense presentation
of this being a fentanyl drug death
it's just not there from previous cases
you're saying that's right
dr sarah weck thank you so much for
being with us here this evening
thank you thanks coming up next the
surge of teenagers young
children across the border for mexico
what's behind all of this
we'll find out you're watching brian
ross investigates on the long crime
trial network
turning now to the crisis the white
house says is not a crisis
even as u.s border agents are being
overwhelmed by a surge
teenager and children coming across the
border from mexico
with rhonda the numbers growing almost
every day
while there's often a spring surge
officials report
in the month of february alone they
detained over 9 400 unaccompanied minors
just this past month brian
we're joined now by john carlos frey
documentary filmmaker and journalist
who's been covering developments at the
border for years john how do we explain
this latest surge that's going on what
is going on
it's complicated brian i wish there was
just one reason
why kids are coming but for the most
part the united states
before joe before biden took office had
kept people from getting into the
country
the the trump administration was
deporting everybody
because of kova they didn't want anybody
to cross the border and that meant
children
also children by tradition the united
states does not deport children
we allow them in we bring them in we
shelter them
and we try to look for their family
members and reunite them the trump
administration was not doing that every
time a child tried to cross the border
the trump administration would deport
them and they usually
stayed in ports of entry like tijuana
and juarez so for the past year
kids were not getting in there's been a
backlog kids have been waiting sometimes
by themselves
in strange cities and as soon as biden
took
office that order to deport our children
was rescinded
and we see this big influx also
there's a lot of issues and problems
going on in central america
that are causing children to come to the
border so it's a very complicated issue
and lastly i think that we have to
realize this happens every year
springtime when the weather gets a
little bit warmer before it gets too hot
that's when we usually see the big spike
in migration so we're seeing all of
those factors added together
john are these children traveling on
their own are they with parents
the children for the most part if you
can believe it or not are traveling by
themselves
we're talking about 13 year olds who
actually make this journey
over a thousand miles in some cases to
the u.s mexico border
it is known in many of these sending
countries especially in central america
that children
are allowed into the united states that
children will be cared for
we also need to know that children grow
up a lot faster in these countries
kids are working at age 12 13 14 years
old
they are almost adults so if their
parents can't make it
they're going to make that journey a lot
of them also are trying to reunite maybe
their parents are already in the united
states
and they're trying to find a way to meet
up with their parents and rejoin them
so yeah i've seen them i've seen trains
filled with children what we would call
children making this journey all by
themselves
i'm catching up with the caravan once
they've already been on the road for a
month
traveled almost a thousand miles and are
arriving in mexico city
i find a lot of people who worked on
farms and say that they fled
because of the drought
this year in just one dry corridor
country
honduras 80 percent of the corn and bean
crops
were lost you've reported again and
again about the impact of climate change
and the devastating impact it's had on
central american countries
that's still the case i think i think
that's what we're really seeing
here it hasn't really been explored in
depth if we take a look at
why people are coming from central
america especially
there is now we're beginning the sixth
year of the drought
there are 450 000 people in central
american countries
that are at starvation levels
these are people who cannot live off the
land it's primarily an agricultural
region
and if you can withstand five or six
years of drought
that's what's happening these people
have tried everything
there are no jobs covett has hit
everybody really hard there
there's a high level of unemployment
there's high crime
where do you go what do you do if you
can't find a job you can't feed your
family you can't raise crops
and and these are usually the conditions
that we see there and there's
they seem to be getting worse climate
change
seems to be the cause of the drought
right now not only that
it's not just drought but we're talking
about weather extremes just this past
year
honduras experienced one of the largest
hurricanes that they have in their
entire history
it wiped out villages and towns farmland
so people aren't able to work like they
used to so when president biden
says in his interview with abc please
don't come
i can say quite clearly don't come and
we're in the process of getting set up
and it's not going to take a whole long
time is to be able to apply for asylum
in place so don't leave
your town or city or community
does that have any impact at all please
don't come i the conditions that i just
described to you
don't really remedy anything please
don't come
is is a nothing compared to these people
if you can imagine what it would take
to allow your 13 year old your 13 year
old
to make this dangerous journey it's not
a light decision please don't come
doesn't mean anything here
this decision is weighed heavily they've
tried absolutely everything else by the
time
a 13 year old gets on a train or a bus
to head to the united states
everything else has been tried there are
no other options this is a very last
resort maneuver
i always think of a child getting to the
u.s mexico border
as the canary in the coal mine we don't
usually see children migrating
that is a very last resort sort we
rarely see women migrating it's usually
able-bodied men who come to work in the
united states
and send money back home if children are
showing up
it's a very serious problem and uh and a
wish by the president of the united
states isn't going to change that all
right john carlos frey documentary
filmmaker and journalist thank you so
much
for being with us here tonight thanks
brian's pleasure
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by
mediaite
abc's martha raddatz asking the tough
questions of the biden white house
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
in maiden we begin with the first winner
of the day
martha redditz my old friend and
colleague from abc news taking on the
biden white house
always ready to ask the tough questions
as she did last sunday on the program
this week com
i i i know you're trying to get that
message out now but your team was also
briefed by career professionals at dhs
during the transition
about the possibility of this crisis you
yourself say we were
we are on pace to have one of the
largest migrant surges in 20 years
why were you not prepared for this
martha raddatz don't tangle her right
aidan
right so that was secretary of homeland
security alejandro majorcas
and he made the rounds on the sunday
shows this weekend in light of the surge
of migrants at the southern border
which has raised questions about the
biden administration's handling of the
immigrants that are coming
to the border from central america
majorcas made the rounds on the sunday
shows this weekend he was on cnn
he was on face the nation who's on meet
the press uh he was on fox news sunday
getting interviewed by chris wallace
who's always a great interrogator
uh but in our opinion martha raddatz had
the best interview with mjorkas
um she pressed him on the treatment of
undocumented
migrants uh and minors at the border uh
she pressed him on
uh media access to uh border uh
and customs patrol facilities down there
um and she also as you saw in that video
um questioned him on why the biden
administration wasn't prepared
for this surge at the border given that
they knew that something like this would
happen
and miraculous response is basically
that the biden administration that is
going to take time for the body
administration
to be able to respond to this after the
trump administration basically
dismantled
the process for processing uh migrants
coming across the border
it was one of the best interviews we saw
among many that new yorkers did this
weekend
so we named martha raddis winner for
that reason
and no surprise that she would do just
that and for the loser a big interview
with
former president trump from fox news
with a major gaffe watch this
you know i want to get to this because
it's just happened now and i want to
double check this with our producers
um the dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
has resigned mr president i'm not
surprised
good that's a big victory for our
country hold on
let me let let me stop let me stop let
me listen to my team one more time
forgive me forgive me that has not
happened
how could that happen aidan i mean
absolutely brutal mistake uh from harris
faulkner the the fox anchor you know you
can
kind of tell what happened here i my
best bet and fox news has just blamed
this on an error the result of
uh the programming being remote right
now and everyone working from home
uh what i assume happened is you know
president trump has uh
been criticizing alejandro mjorkas uh
quite uh
harshly um he sent out a statement last
night
uh criticizing him for his appearances
on the sunday shows and defending
the biden's administration uh
immigration policies and
i what i assume happened is a producer
said something that harris faulkner
along the lines of
are you calling for alejandro mjorkas to
resign she thought that he was saying
that alejandro marcus had resigned
um she obviously broke in with that news
that would have been a huge story and
she had the former president on the
phone
to react to it uh i can only imagine
what a producer was saying in her ear
after she had falsely announced that the
department of homeland security
secretary had just resigned
um she did a clean-up job she apologized
for it and fox news issued a statement
saying
we're sorry that this happened um still
a major major flub for
uh for an anchor to make during a live
interview with the former president
and all of us who rely on the little
pieces of uh audio coming through our
ears are that can happen and your heart
goes out to uh this faulkner but
at fox news they they should really do a
better job than that
i mean one just has to think that when
you hear something like that a producer
say something like that you should
confirm it before announcing it
reporting it on air
um particularly given it doesn't sound
like the you know the i can't imagine
the producer was particularly
um you know confident in the end of the
claim that majorcas had just resigned so
the fact that faulkner did not you know
take a step back
say let me double check this get the
statement up um get some further
evidence to support the claim
um that the dhs secretary had just
resigned um i mean that that's a big
flub
and of course it's very terrible you
know she's live she's interviewing the
former president
um it's it's hard to put it to put
yourself in her shoes but it's a pretty
serious mistake and i i guess
it's her credit right then and there
seconds later
all right all right thanks aiden thanks
all of you for watching and have a good
evening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you